the knives are out for the world's
richest man elon musk subject to more
vicious attacks from the left after
buying twitter for 44 billion dollars in
pledging to let free speech reign
supreme on the platform watch
twitter is not the government twitter is
a private company that can say no you're
not allowed to be a nazi on twitter
there was a time when people had the
double hashtags around their names
because they were jewish and right
wingers were saying get in the oven
anytime you made any benign comment on
twitter they attacked women that you
know the misogyny was crazy on twitter
for a while elon musk i guess he you
know he misses the old south africa in
the 80s he wants he wants that back
but musk remains undeterred by the
critics he is slamming twitter's
decision to center the hunter biden
laptop story calling it incredibly
inappropriate and he just tweeted this a
moment ago quote for twitter to deserve
public trust it must be politically
neutral which effectively means
upsetting the far right and the far left
equally i don't know if they're equally
upset greg um but remember that song by
cindy lauper the true colors yes that's
what you're seeing now the media they
got blue colors coming out exactly i
can't love a story more than this story
it's like we got a free election result
you know in which we won and we get to
see all the people who dislike us not
that we dislike that but who dislike us
a breakdown in public it really is like
2016 except instead of trump winning the
first amendment won
isn't that beautiful
yeah joy reid has built a foolproof
career insurance plan she she is like
she has msnbc so terrified that like
they can't fire her because she's just
going to call them racists too she calls
everybody racist
and that's her game and that's her scam
and the msnbc
management are cowards for letting her
do this but that's what they chose to do
i think musk pointing out the new york
post story is this message to the
company uh censor was the uh legal chief
um vijaya
gaddy i think her name is that your days
of getting rich off woke censorship and
ideological targeting is over this is a
woman that made tens of millions of
dollars in her role and then she's
crying she's crying because she's just
about to be fired
one of the things that i was curious
about judge is that apparently elon musk
signed an agreement that said i won't
criticize the company
but is pointing out i'm just wondering
what the twitter people probably think
that he's criticizing the company if
he's suggesting that it was highly
inappropriate to press the laptop well
he's criticizing the company by showing
up or by buying the company that's all
they need i mean what you just heard was
lunacy that that that elon musk is
longing for apartheid from the south
african apartheid what kind of lunacy is
that look you know greg has said this a
million times we don't know what elon
musk's politics are but all he has to
say is this like i believe in the first
amendment
i believe in free speech and these
people on the on the left are saying you
know what um
those people aren't going to protect
democracy well isn't free speech
democracy and and who do they think that
they're that they're talking to because
americans get what they're saying and
it's evident by everyone getting this
huge increase in twitter followers now
that the dialer apparently is being
released so yeah the one thing geraldo
that they that the right and the left
seem to agree on is that elon musk has
said he will do all they can to make
sure that the bots are banned from the
uh platform which i think people would
welcome what do you make of the
continued like frenzied meltdown about
it i'm shocked that this story has had
legs that's now into the third or fourth
day it was a shocking to me because to
me is a one-day story business story it
was uh it was interesting and exciting
when i thought that trump may be coming
back uh i i think that uh
elon musk is the future
of uh of competent private
enterprise i i love his alan i love his
uh
his creativity you give the guy i went
through his uh resume when i heard joe
reed say that about a poor tight he left
south africa he was 17 years old uh you
know he there's never any evidence on
the wreck as far as i know that he has
an ounce of racism in him uh so other
than the fact that he's a white guy for
her to make this kind of attack is so
scurrilous it's so low down and dirty
to me and that and uh greg mentions the
bosses at msnbc you know i worked at
cnbc for a long time where the hell are
they yeah how is it that you're allowed
to like the one thing like elon musk
said for example it is incredibly
inappropriate
for twitter to kill the uh the hunter
biden laptop story i mean who disagrees
with that now that the washington post
the new york times everybody said the
laptop is is legit
and uh what it contained was so
outrageous i mean i mean there will be a
story in any administration that you're
your kid you're only as happy as you're
unhappy as kid but this kid was like
doing uh this drug and that drug and
screwing this uh widow of his brother
who knows what he did and the widow's
sister and the cowboy and the widow's
sister yes that's right i would forget
about that yeah
jessie's sister
elon musk cancels their day of rest
wow well what day is that it's sunday
everyone no it's every once in a while
they get a full day of rest like a
couple weeks ago they had one because
elon musk suggested he was going to buy
the car remember that's the same thing
that happened after trump won the
election i think my sister's school gave
the whole day off yeah oh yeah they were
black and they lit candles
elon musk is the new trump he is the new
bad guy in the country that they are
going to thrash and throttle until they
can bleed him dry so he doesn't even
want twitter anymore maybe he'll just
fly off into space and say see you later
this guy is going to be investigated by
the sec by the justice department they
are going to destroy him as hard as
possible and any negative thing that
happens on the platform say someone goes
and shoots somebody and they find and
they trace it they like that death at
his doorstep any negative thing that
happens that is blood on his hands it's
not like he's also saying there's not
going to be moderation
he's saying they're going to moderate
you're not allowed to go there and say
i'm going to kill everybody they're
going to moderate it they're just not
going to rig it and that's why they're
so upset joy reads a joke and who owns
comcast is it brian roberts does he
still own do they own nbc or whatever
that is
someone needs to ask brian roberts just
show him a clip
of joy reid take it into his board room
and say are you comfortable with this
paying this woman on your airwaves to
say these kind of things there's no way
in hell he would be comfortable
listening to that on his own airways you
probably just guaranteed her next
contract well maybe i did well she's
great for us because she's plenty of
content last thing it's ironic the guy's
this climate warrior two years ago they
loved the guy because he was saving the
planet now they tried to save twitter
and he's like the doctor even yeah they
want they'll probably want to tank tesla
next
tesla better watch out they're coming
for him all right i had president
biden's dhs secretary making a very
stunning claim about biden's handling of
the border crisis
hi i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do
me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe
right now